outwardly there are a few Clues to what
happened in this house
maybe the gamer's chair on the property
of Jack Tashira from here he shared
National secrets on a gaming platform
online
it is a huge story in a small town
neighbors are digesting details of the
Scandal next door I feel sad for the
whole situation I feel sad for
Young Jack as the word implies he is
Young Jack you know he's a young man
um
who uh I really don't know what his
thoughts were but clearly I feel for him
um
you know we don't know the extent of the
league I don't think anyone knows that
but I pray that's minimal damage from
that
but we also know that you know there's
some level of accountability but I also
pray for some mercy for him
the family of the young Airman attended
a Boston court hearing where he appeared
in handcuffs and a beige prison uniform
Jack Tashira is accused of retaining
classified documents and transmitting
National Defense information
documents like this which we've
partially blurred it's from nearly two
months ago the box that can be read
appears to show details of Special
Forces troops in Ukraine including 50
from the UK
before his arrest by the FBI Tashira had
leaked hundreds of documents to an
online chat room material used to brief
senior U.S military officials the most
senior of all spoke of increasing
security as he boarded Air Force One on
his way home from Ireland
did the department to make sure that
they get to the root of
assessed in the first place number one
and number two to focus extensively on
the extent to which it all occurred
the story that started here continues to
reverberate around the world as the
United States assesses the damage and
deals with the Fallout internationally
it is a shocking story
it is shock felt acutely in this corner
of Massachusetts
we have a lot of military Connections in
this community so it's like it's more
surprising that somebody out of here
would have
you know the gall to kind of do it it's
local concern for a matter of National
Security and it shared far beyond the
tone where the till began James Matthews
Sky News in North Dighton Massachusetts